we're back in it
boxing for aquaman 2.
last time was two years ago
what's up everybody carlos here jason
mamoa is back and gearing up for aquaman
2 and as is superhero movie tradition
you got a new movie means you got a new
look taken to instagram on monday mo
more posted aquaman's new fit writing
second round new suit more action
director james wan also took to
instagram to explain that the new suit
will be titled the stealth suit adding
that aquaman's outfit will be made of
atlantean tech based on a cephalopod's
camouflaging ability juan added that he
and screenwriter david leslie johnson
the goldrick were inspired by the blue
suit from the 80s comic aquaman isn't
the only one getting a makeover as
arthur is dressing up his half-brother
orm played by patrick wilson is
decidedly more dressed down this time
around exactly how aquaman will obtain
the stealth suit is still unknown but
its inclusion is a hint that the new
movie storyline could draw inspiration
from the classic comics it first
appeared in we'll know for sure when
aquaman and the lost kingdom hits
theaters december 16th 2022 what do you
think of the new suit it's not quite as
comics accurate as the orange armor but
in this case
no that might be a good thing do you
agree let me know in the comments below
you